blog mas numero 20 siamo quasi alla fine
oggi è un giorno speciale perché si va a
napoli il traffico appena partiti per
napoli grazie potuto tornare a roma
perché dovevo prendere il regalo di
luigi per natale che nikon sabato invece
graziana inquadrati ti prego prendere
questo messaggio
allora non è vero mi ha chiesto di poi
di viaggiare insieme si si hai bisogno
di qualcuno vuole sfogarsi arrivare a
napoli
un'ora il 40 fa sono ancora a roma
appena partiti
arriveremo alle tre e mezza se tutto va
bene è una macchina fermare la macchina
color salmone nella zona strada se
nevicasse quella macchina sarebbe una
macchia il santissimo
[Musica]
il milan ha compiuto zuccherata è un po
di sicuro kakà musicali
ma dove siamo dove siamo per nulla
guarda ci sono impianti boschi siamo
aspetta oggi lo dice non siamo a via di
rocca cencia che non sono come la uno
pensa chi ci vuole tipo la musica del
far west
[Musica]
meno male che c'è caro meraviglia e ceo
del sud per strada vabbè ci siamo resi
conto che abbiamo fatto che poteva
benissimo andare a prendere l'autostrada
sin da subito ma ways ci aveva detto di
andare qui ora siamo imbottigliati un
traffico un treno pure imbottigliato in
cui pietro tutti imbottigliati a bergen
dell'india vito nella ridente località
di labico matoka vedete sospetti ma non
riuscire a vedere l'abito aspettate
abbia fatto un cambio mi sono fatto
crescere i capelli si chiama noi è come
parte
[Musica]
prospero anche i felici
una donna senza polmoni
la bellezza non tramonto sto facendo una
ripresa di un tramonto ti blog fanno
schifo se sono arrivato a riprendere
tramonti io vi chiedo perdono richiedo
gli chiedo scusa dal profondo del mio
cuore tanto non sarò né a fuoco e ne
riprese non vedo niente mostrano
accompagnando graziana perché in realtà
dovevamo in teoria accompagnarla da
luigi poi qualcuno i suoi familiari
numerosi sono dei suoi numerosi inizio
alcuni su numerosi famigliari avrebbe
preso a nessuno l'ha preso nessuno
nessuno vuole bene si stanno facendo la
città i capelli dalla sarda sono si
stanno macchiando il grinch e dietro il
crisi perché ha deciso di scendere da
roma a napoli per vedere tutta la mia
solidarietà alle persone che magari
lavorano al nord e devono tornare a casa
per le feste
ragazzi io col cuore vi raggiungo in
questo momento non con la macchina ha
guidato ce l'ha fatta se la nostra
eroina ed è con sommo gaudio
ma ecco la felicità che si ottiene con
così tanta fatica che finalmente
arrivato a casa di luce ma questo è un
sogno ma con chi sei a letto
quindi ho scoperto un tradimento
togliti schifosa
come ti sei permesso di prendere il mio
uomo come potuto farmi questo vorrei
dire un attimo per una cosa meravigliosa
giulia alla mamma di lui aveva preparato
a pranzo perché speravo che arrivasse a
pranzo la quale tenero delle mozzarelle
e la pasta volevo ngo le tv così dopo
volevo scoperto fra te e questa
peripatetica allora io dormo qui è tutto
nomi li basta dire che se hai capito
il ragazzo perfetto tiriamo fuori un
pochino capita di roba vera e cruda
ecco togliendo che cos'è questo ragazzi
qui abbiamo il bouquet di luigi ma solo
di giocatori bravi 18 anni di nuovo
l'ermo fermo almeno vinale cos'è questa
cosiddetto fammi vedere mi vergogno ma
poi bene a vergognarsi per accettarlo
passato su che cos'è che stai facendo
qui sto facendo qui invece dovevo venire
fuori da queste chiavi
vabbè ma l'affare cani a questa era
carina e quindi deciso di farla vedere
casi vediamo questa ok ok ma la macchina
cosa era sexy ero piccolo ho 18 anni mi
pub bar o da quella carina sacra che
andrà su incorniciato in nome di quelle
cene scendono da sei incorniciata questo
che cos'è il tuo biglietto da visita
ciao ragazzi da tutte le varie tra
l'altro dove sia in india un mi stavi
d'addio questa giornata e quindi parenti
io sto con un'ex modella a me diceva lei
lei cavalli cavalli
se questo era vero invece che quelle
dove sei piccole ceneri si è tutti bocca
di cosa del regno di moda c'è abbastanza
modesto rilascia su questo canale grazie
perché una mangiata quel monte
ridottissimo tra dai questa è una cosa
positiva
in che senso ha scoperto il seno a keita
cosa i tuoi diari tuoi video a non i
diari segreti
no ma che avrei polato al jolie diano i
sedimenti avrei donati ha preparato per
l'occasione però che cos'è uno può
attese di gianello grava siamo riusciti
a entrare in possesso di loro dei
bozzetti ma quanti di quanti anni sono
tipo 40 anni fa 20 20 anni fa e come
facevi scusa mini senza internet senza
la possibilità all'università navi in
carrozza e m esistevano quindi nei m
da allora qui abbiamo dei film bello
scatto doveva questo chiederemo lei
aveva questa specie di carpa sotto e
aveva comunque un principio di bronchite
e desidera influenzata lei sirena hanno
le k e carpa l'hai fatto apposta ma ci
avrebbe potuto camminare questa qui volo
questo sì a fatica molto abbiamo lei che
uscirà quartieri spagnoli
elabora un po così un pop up shop
bello bellissimo questo sempre principio
che le guarda ma lasciatemi stare sono
pazza vi prego lasciatemi stare un passo
europea cosa che ho trovato sbam pazza
questo è quello che hanno scelto poi lui
e anche lei totalizzate ripassare di
passare ha dato l'attuale portiere che
ho cucito lui ma festive fatto il
cappellino e così un tacco semplice una
cosa semplice vedi che è un bustino
vogliono mettere a quella sporca sporche
odiosa guarda così come si sempre come
semplice ecco che fra l'altro guardo le
bocce sono talmente per chi non lo
sapesse luigi è uno stilista genere ecco
perché fa tutte queste cose e ha
studiato anche perché noi più care del
tuo ecco perché insomma la magone fatto
metterti con l'anticristo del fashion ma
tre faccette non ho preso una pancetta
sì non è vero sto per andare cassette
alla prova la cina e nel real
addio ragazzo è stato meraviglioso che
viene chiediamo domani con bony
penultima of mass alle 14 ma da bagnato
ciao